Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
What's going on here.
Guys. This is Rob and we are back with X's swords.
We're on part technically I think this is part 14.
I know we combined combined two parts together.
So I think we're officially one behind, uh, what the official numbering is,
but it doesn't really matter. Uh, we're still going in order fields,
the guys who were looking to catch up,
you'll find the playlist down in the description. So you're not,
you don't feel like you're kind of left out and because I know we're covering a
lot of stories right now. So a lot of you guys may feel a little bit lost, uh,
check out the playlist down to the description and that will give you everything
you need to get caught up on the X-Men. So, ah,
what we'll end up doing here is we pick up with the official start of the
tournament, right? The official start of the duel between Coca-Cola and a Rocco.
And this the initially starts out with Jubilee, resting alongside Shogo light,
shadow, being a dragon that was once human and form and all that kind of stuff.
Anyway, it's kind of like her adopted kid more or less,
but the idea is that in the middle of taking this nap,
she's suddenly met by a kind of telepathic message that essentially tells her,
like, there's not a whole lot of time here,
but in case you don't hear back from me, just know that things kind of went bad.
Right. But I also care about, you know, this,
of course this message is coming directly from, from Betsy Bradick right?
The new captain Britain kind of a funny thing here.
And I don't think he was given an official designation until recently,
but Brian Bradick because he doesn't really wheel the amulet of right instead.
And now he's using this sort of MYP. Uh, he's basically captain Avalon.
That's really how that works now. But the idea is that,
of course this kind of telepathic communication is cut off. Now Jubilees says,
if I don't hear back from you by noon, like I'll come over there,
but I'll come over there and find out what's going on. Now of course,
the reason why this message was cut off is because Betsy Bradick was interrupted
and you know, talking to Jubilee by ISCA, the unbeatable.
And so it was one of these funny little things because ISCA has this kind of
conversation where she talks to her and says, Hey,
like you have the Knight of swords, right? Like that's an ill omen.
And it's kind of like, you know, when we get out there, uh, you know, it,
it's not too late for you to quit,
but it's not too late for you to like give up. That's what you choose to do.
And the response of Betsy Bradley was like, that's not going to happen,
but I'm not going to quit. Like I'm not going to give up. And it's like,
his whole idea is like, you shouldn't embarrass yourself out there. Right? Like,
I mean, that doesn't need to happen.
Like just give up now while everything's okay. Now keep in mind,
this is not ISCA being kind and being friendly.
It's her basically taunting Betsy Bradley. Right? Like you can't win against me.
So the best thing for you to do is to give up, but it's to just quit.
And it's one of these things where she kind of says like,
of course it's not going to happen. And her response is,
I'm just giving you some advice, right? Unbeatable is not just a name. And,
and the funny thing is that when Betsy asks ISCA, like your sorts called mercy,
right? She's like, don't get excited. That one is just a name, right?
So when we get out there, I'm not stopping against you.
Like I'm not holding back, I'm going to kill you. Right? Because keep in mind,
this whole tournament is for keeps, right? This is,
this is a fight to the death. That's what every single one of these battles is.
And so what we end up doing is picking up with the officials,
started the tournament with a handful of people from other world here.
Now on the surface, it kind of looks like, man, there's like nobody here, right?
Like nobody cares about this tournament.
The reality of this is that as being held in such a way to where it's
reminiscent of tournaments back during the era of, of like the dark ages,
not really the dark ages, but like Knights and Kings and so on and so forth.
That's how these kinds of tournaments were held. Right?
They were relatively small, get togethers, different things.
I thought they weren't huge.
It wasn't like the Roman coliseums where you would have thousands of people who
were there all lining the stands. There were never really that big,
I guess Hollywood's kind of made it look like it was that big,
but they were never really all that large in the first place.
The other thing here is that Brian Bradick looks like the burger King guy from
those creepy burger King commercials. I just want to throw that out there.
That just needs to be said,
I am 100% confident in stating here that was the intention
because he is kind of a creep and he is a King and he loves burgers.
So I guess it's only a matter of time before they made him look like the burger
King. But having said that once ISCA and Betsy, Brad had come out here,
run on the side of the Coca-Cola it's like, come on, Betsy, you got this,
you got this. Right. But notice apocalypse,
he's just kind of watching this whole thing go down because he's kind of like,
okay, it's Betsy Bradick versus ISCA.
The unbeatable what's the likelihood she can actually win here.
And then once the fight starts, right?
Like you have apocalypse kind of chimes in and says, you know,
we're where captain Britain's like, man,
she's got listened to bag the responsive of, of apocalypse as well.
I've learned not to underestimate the, the heart and,
and try to trust in the heart and the passion of young people.
But understand Betsy Bradick is not that old, right? I mean, she's not,
she's not been around as a fighter for a very long time. She was a telepath.
She was an X man. Sure.
She has the powers or the ability she had when she was Quentin for a little
while when she switched bodies, would that Japanese Ninja,
but SCA has been alive for centuries.
Her skills have been honed for centuries.
This is a girl that does not have the ability to lose and has also been fighting
with a sword for longer than most all of you have been alive. Right?
The only person here that I would say has been alive longer than ESCO or
anywhere close to. However long it's been,
has been alive is apocalypse everybody else here, every single X-Men,
every single, every single person for Precoa has been alive that long. Right?
Seemingly the blink of an eye and all of [inaudible] lifespan.
And so when that happens, once the fight kicks off, things go kind of bonkers,
right? Because you have Betsy Bradick,
who's sort of intimidating a little bit and say, you can't lose.
That just means you never learn how to win a fight or never,
never learned how to fight anybody at all. And this was like, okay, cool.
Let me prove you wrong.
She literally attached and shatters the sores of Betsy Brodick,
which in turn shatters, Betsy Bradick herself,
the whole fight is over that fast. Like it was literally two hits, right?
It was Betsy Bradick hitting ISCA and then ISCA hitting Betsy Bradick and then
Bessie Braddock was destroyed just that fast.
And so from there sat a needed step stand.
This is the fight really over that fast,
what kind of sucks like Mel was expecting it to be a little bit longer than that
because apparently she ended up showing up here late.
Now a lot of the guys are going to look at that and say,
that kind of sucks to the fight is over that fast, right there.
Should've been more to it than that. That's going to be a common theme,
not because of the fact that Jonathan Hickman is cheating us out of the story,
but because there's actually some pretty nefarious stuff going on here and we'll
find out more of what that looks like here in a little bit. But from here,
we switch over to Doug Ramsey right over to cipher and it's called gets drawn,
which means he's supposed to be ready to fight.
But the response that our neem is like, you know,
this little party that we're having, it's definitely going to be a challenge.
And your friend here better get used to learning how to speak every language,
any learn how to do it fast.
And the reason why is because he's kind of led away by a handful by like three
gorgeous girls. Now I don't understand this about cipher, right?
He's literally being led away by gorgeous girls. And he's like, Hey,
let go of me. Where are you taking me guys help? Not me man.
Like if I were a single man and I was being led away by three gorgeous girls,
I'd be like, yes, ladies take me. But at the same time,
they also end up taking one of the, one of the fighters from Morocco side.
And so where they,
where you initially had like store maybe a couple people who interject and say
like,
we have to do something through responsible rain after that vision that he saw,
because I had a lot of, a couple of the guys ask him this question. Um,
nothing that Wolverine saw actually came to fruition.
It was a glimpse of what could happen if he actually did kill Saturday or if
cacoa lost the tournament. Right. So it was just kind of a glimpse there.
So again, it was all basically in his head, but you ended up having, you know,
stormy kind of challenges that, and Wolverine's like, no,
like we are not going to turn against the rules. If we win this,
we have to win legit. Right. Anything other than that, and we will,
it'll lead to the ruin of alt.
And so these girls are kinda kind of lead cipher away. They lead this,
this other, this other chick away. And then from there,
they take them into a kind of tent of sorts.
And it's kind of nuts because Brian Brodick looks to apocalypse and he was like,
like, you had me worried that Betsy Bradick would be humiliated, not destroyed.
And the responsible pocalypse is, are you really that stupid?
We came here at a tournament,
this literally designed to determine the fate of our, of our dimensions.
And this is obviously a fight to the death. Did you really believe,
believe that nobody was going to die?
Did you really believe that was going to happen? Brian Bradley,
are you really that dumb? Like it's, it's kind of funny, right?
It's kind of hilarious, but he's like,
I don't know why you ever thought this journey would be without sacrifice,
right? Some of us will return home changed.
Some of us will not return home at all.
Now this is an important thing to understand here,
because you remember with Betsy, Bradick basically being destroyed more or less.
That means if they try to resurrect her in Krakatoa,
that she'll come back a different version of herself, right? This is,
this is one of the things that I mentioned when they previously introduced this
at the very beginning of extra sorts. This is a way for Marvel to soft reboot,
right? And that's what we see happening a lot, right?
Over the years of Marvel comics, those guys, you don't,
you don't really get that over the years of Marvel comics,
their way of rebooting was totally different from DCS.
DC would not really soft reboot characters. They would hard reboot, right?
They would do event like crisis on infinite earths.
They would do something like, like infinite crisis or new 50 T,
which honestly crisis on infinite earths.
And the new 52 are the only times that DC really hard rebooted their entire
landscape. Uh, but what you'll get after those are mini crises, right?
So you got crisis on defendant earth and then you've got zero hour.
Then you got infinite crisis and you got final crisis.
Those were designed to basically fix plot threads that had been left over after
the events of a, of Christ on earth.
You also get stories like black estate brightest tonight,
and the green lantern mythos. That was a soft reboot, right?
You get these small little things that are done here and there in DC to kind of
bring small things back or change characters or something along those lines and
Marvel, that's all they do. Marvel never hard reboots, right?
Marvel's never had an instance of the history of their publication line,
what it was like, you know, Marvel number zero, or you know,
Spider-Man number zero. And this guy number zero iron man, number zero,
captain American numbers zero. And it was just aligned wide reboot.
That's never happened, I think is a problem. That's never happened,
but that's never actually happened. Instead what Marvel does is stuff like this,
right? So if Manuel, if Jonathan Hickman wants to rework, you know,
Betsy brought it. If you looked at her character and he says, okay,
over the years, she's kind of grown stagnant.
And her history has been really weird and really shuffled and has kind of been a
hassle to follow because it has right. Is anybody, let me tell you something,
man, anybody who knows anything about the publication history,
or even just the end universe history of Betsy Bradick will tell you it's a
hassle, but it's an absolute nightmare to understand that.
But if Hickman sits down and looks at that and says, yeah,
we should rework Betsy Bradick. This is the way they do it. Right.
She dies here in other world,
which means that they can't bring her back to the way she was when they
resurrector.
It'll just be some random version of herself from across the multi-verse,
which means whatever version we get is going to more or less,
be a soft reboot of character.
She's going to have a whole new history and all that kind of stuff.
Why she's going to have to learn to probably reintegrate herself back into the
X-Men things are going to be different.
We might even get kind of a little bit of history of her own universe along the
way, but whatever it is, she's going to come out different than she was before.
The only exception to that is if she somehow reconstituted here the way she was
and nothing's changed at all, right.
But if she stays dead and they resurrect her and Coca-Cola,
then it'll be a soft reboot of our character, right?
So just kind of something to keep in mind. Now we're Douglas Ramsey is led away,
right? This other person from a Rocco, this led away is a woman called Bay,
the blood moon.
And the idea behind this is that they has a set of powers that are almost
identical to the powers of black bolt of the Inhumans.
Right then once she can do is she can basically release something called a doom
note.
And this is essentially just a giant concussive force of energy that comes out
of her mouth in the form of her voice. But what she's learned is that over,
over time, it's not necessarily just like black folk, right?
In the sense that when Blackbelt speaks, he's got a quasi Sonic. Great.
So we cannot talk and not scream at the same time.
The only way for him to do that is to like transition this essence to a
different realm or for Dr. Strange to create some kind of pocket place where he
can talk and his powers are neutralized or something along those lines.
But if he's just walking mean down the street on earth or traveling anywhere
within the normal universe in, in the main Marvel universe, if he talks,
he's going to kill somebody with, with, uh, with Bay,
what she learned is she has that power,
but she can also talk at the same time so she can channel it at any point in
time.
So think of it like a vocal version of Cyclops is optic glass when he's wearing
his optic visor, right. That he can look around when he has his optic visor on,
but he can also channel his powers if he wants to at the same time,
that's kind of how that works. And so because of this, uh,
one of the things that goes on with this doom note is that it works a little
uniquely with Doug Ramsey. And this sends a,
Doug has the ability to understand any language,
but he can't understand hers because hers is a language that doesn't exist
within the main Marvel universe. Right? I mean, I guess it does,
but a Rocco has been so far removed from anything in the main mobile universe.
It's a language nobody in the universe has ever encountered before. And so,
because of that, the do note itself, the,
the kind of power in the voice of Bay desires to be understood what it wants to
be, wants somebody to, to hear it and to understand what it's saying, but the,
the words you speak, there's not really a true language and she cannot,
it cannot really be translated.
And so it was almost kind of like this vocal slash linguistics version of a,
an immovable force meeting, an unstoppable object, that kind of a thing it's,
it's kind of crazy, you know, with this, this, a little bit of a thing here,
but the whole reason why they're being brought together is really kind of
brought to bear when you have a magic visiting Doug and the two of them kind of
start talking about what's going on. And he's like,
I have no idea what's happening. Like what's, what's going on right here.
And she's like, well, Brian's pretty inconsolable. He's pretty off.
And everybody else's as well. Uh, they're just kind of, you know,
mingling with the, the Iraqi people a little bit more,
but no one really feels friendly towards this guy where they're all kind of off
at her because she'd killed Betsy. But, uh, as the,
as the doors open and they start to step in that Doug realizes, Oh my God, like,
Bay's not going to kill me in a tournament. She's going to marry me. Like,
it's literally a marriage has kind of been a symbol here.
Now here's the funny thing about this, right?
Teenie Howard plays this fast and loose. It's just kinda like, okay, like,
Doug's like, all right, cool. I'm going to get married now. Here's the thing,
man. Right? Like you see the two of them standing next to each other.
This is a big woman. Right. And not in terms of, not in terms of girth,
but just in terms of like physical size. She's like what?
Maybe like two heads taller than, than Douglas Ramsey. Right.
She's got maybe like a foot on him. All right. Let me tell you something cipher.
She's going to make a man out of you, man.
Yes, she does. She's going to miss. She's gonna make a meal out of him.
Better be ready. But, uh, but nonetheless,
this is kind of a crazy thing because the time comes for them to like make their
doubts. And he's like, I mean, I didn't prepare any valves inside and he's like,
well, then you better prepare them. You better, you better do a quick,
fast in a hurry. And he actually makes these pretty amazing thousands of fly,
right? He says, Bay, the blood moon, right?
This is a little absurd because I don't know anything about you,
but you're going to be my wife.
So I swear to uphold my value for the duration of this challenge or whatever,
however long it goes after.
And I'll always be grateful that we got to do this instead of sword fight,
because I'm not really ready.
To die. They're.
Not bad bowels right now in response to that, uh, they offers her vows,
which are really good as well. Right?
She says like when the grim fog of bloodshed overtakes us,
the beloved is the beacon that returns us to our better selves.
Love is a failed heat that cannot be broken.
I will love you with a force of the wave that crashes the shore,
like the current, the swallows, the sand, this is kind of cool.
It's pretty interesting. And so he's kind of like on me,
I don't really understand anything you said. It's just really,
really fascinating. And then she, she fuels, she pulls back to Vail and uh,
and Doug's like, man, she's super hot, right?
So we just immediately swept up and how gorgeous this girl is.
And so from there, like in the middle of this wedding,
fire just goes everywhere.
Fire.
Just gets sprayed everywhere. And here comes Jubilee, riding show go.
And everybody's like, Jubilee, what are you doing? Like,
what are you doing here? Like you're flying in here with a dragon.
Like here comes a clue. Trains. You believe the last stop is you.
This is not a good idea. You should not do this.
You should not fly in here with a dragon and start breathing fire everywhere.
But you believe like, well, I told Brett I Betsy Bradley,
but I didn't hear from her by 12.
Did I come over here and see what's going on now?
Here's the crazy thing about this is keep in mind, show goes,
dragon fire in other world has the ability to melt that reality. Right?
He can literally destroy the physical principles that reality. And so when,
when you have, you know, Wolverine, who's kind of like, Hey man,
it's kind of cool.
This Dragon's coming here and he's going to burn the place down.
The response of apocalypse is no, that's not cool at all. Wolverine.
That is not by any means a cool thing. I mean maybe a little bit.
Maybe it's like a little bit cool, but it's not,
it's cool as you're making it out to be right,
because this dragon will destroy the reality in which we live. Right.
And we will all perish along with it. Right.
So killing us is the least of what this dragon can do.
It's kind of a cool little, a cool little thing there now,
while all that's going on, a cipher is kind of like, okay,
like he's talking to babies, like, are you gonna go out there? And she's,
and she doesn't really say anything where he's like,
are you really going to go out there? And you really gonna,
you really gonna do all this? I mean, if you do, here's the thing, like,
don't kill, like, don't kill the dragon. The Dragon's cool.
It's like a little baby, right? Like the Dragon's cool.
Like don't kill the dragon. She immediately turns around and kisses him. Right.
So here's, here's what I'm going to bet. Right? I'm going,
I'm going to bet this here and I'll tell you what, if I'm wrong,
I will give out three Rob Porex right.
I will give three Rob core rings for free, which by the way,
fully got your asking. Ah, we're going to start selling it.
I'll make an announcement later, but I'll give out three,
Rob four rings for free.
What I'm willing to bet here is that the time's going to come when it's time for
cipher to fight.
And she's going to fight in his stead and every single match that he has,
that I doubt the two of them are actually going to have to fight each other.
And if they do have to fight each other, she'll sacrifice her life for him.
And then cypher will basically be the one who wins the tournament.
He'll come out on top and he'll be the one that saves, saves for color.
I will bet that I will bet that's exactly what happens. I don't know if it is,
but I will bet that's what happens now.
The cool thing is that one Saturday and shows up here and realizes what's going
on. She's, right? She's she's eight kinds of off. I just, jeez,
she's mad as hell when she comes, she comes walking out here and she's like,
no, like this is not gonna fly. And, and it's one of the, well, no pun intended,
but it's one of those things where like, she almost intends to destroy it,
but then you have wool Raider kind of times then like that baby's going to hurt
storm. Right. And that's when Saturday realizes, Oh, that's right, it's a baby.
So she uses her magic and then manipulates the mind of,
of Chicago and we're to bring him to her and bring them under her spell. Right.
She also kind of dissipates his dragon fire.
So it can't really destroy anything inside of a,
anything inside of other worlds.
But it's one of these things where she makes this comment where she was like,
you know, it's lucky that I'm in a good mood today, right?
Because if you had actually flown Jubilee here,
I would have killed her in front of everybody.
But I would have killed her in front of every single person here as it was a
little bit, a little bit nuts because from there, you know,
once everything kind of settles down that it's like, okay, she's like,
I'm in a good mood, but I got my drinks. We got a wedding, we have cake, right.
One point for each side, right? Like one point for each person.
And that's where.
It ends. So.
In the first match, right, the first day of this battle, which I won't even lie,
this story kind of went off the rails. And the first day of this battle, ah,
Betsy Bradick died in two hits. And uh,
really just with one hit and cipher got married to a Chicky doesn't know.
So yeah, that's kind of where we are now. Here's the crazy thing about this.
It's only gonna get crazier over that being said, guys,
we're gonna bring this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain it,
make sure you guys have the sub button to become part of the Rob core.
If you guys enjoyed this video, make sure you drop a line.
Mike. I know we'll catch you all later, Bruce.
[Inaudible].